[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down from season two the final
scene blew my mind when I first saw it
and all in all we have a lot to talk
about throughout this video we're going
to be breaking it all down going over
our theories and also what we think is
going on if we have a clue not even
going to ask you for a thumbs up I just
want to get straight into that scene and
talk about exactly what it means for the
future in it we see Tabitha waking up in
hospital and she's finally managed to
make it back to the outside world
realizing she's free she's suddenly hit
with the horror that her family still
trapped there and she simply can't get
back why it's so terrifying is added out
anyone's gonna believe her stories and
there's nowhere to actually get back to
the town through conventional means
although the ending gives us a lot of
questions it actually at least gives us
an answer and debunks a major Theory
throughout the last two seasons many
have suspected that the characters in
the show are in fact dead or that this
clearly isn't the case as we see her
waking up the scrappy a few times this
simply isn't purgatory three and there
are actually some clues about what could
be going on here now one thing that the
characters have said throughout the
seasons is that all this might
potentially be a dream that could be the
case here as there are some things in
this scene that are connected to sleep
and the idea of waking up Tabitha of
course wakes up in the hospital after
getting pushed out the lighthouse and we
discover that she was found unconscious
by hikers in the woods the town itself
is also described as being like a
nightmare and the Monsters themselves
could represent this too cut back to the
start of episode 9 and we have Sarah
talking about the evil entities that
exist there and she theorizes this when
discussing what's happening what if
their fears become part of the forest
this could explain the cicada said her
brother was afraid of and also the Civil
War soldiers that keep popping up Victor
and his mother shared conversations
about this and when we look at the new
deaths they're all connected to dreams
in the first season all our people had
to worry about was making sure that
Talisman was Secure so that when the
monsters did knocking nine doors they
weren't in any trouble things are ramped
up though and if there are fears then we
could learn who these figures represent
and they may potentially be people from
The Real World say one of them was a guy
who got too pushy with a girl or another
was a boss that was abusive to his staff
people would have a genuine fear of
their man it could explain why they
manifest like this now the horror for
season 2 has definitely been elevated
and we've had an extra Dimension added
into the show Boyd's got worms
I got worms and characters like Paula
were killed in their sleep again it ties
back to this idea of dreams and Elgin
and Kenny had them manifesting last week
Elgin of course had a nightmare about
the time as he was arriving and I think
this whole thing shows the root cause of
the problem there seems to be some sort
of hypnosis over the town and the only
way to get out is to go looking for
answers
but looking for answers is our only way
out I don't think there is a way out now
that's how Tabitha escapes and we also
learn that Victor's mother did the same
thing too the lighthouse also represents
several things symbolically and when we
look at literature it backs up the prior
point now lighthouses are typically used
to show safety and a way out Sailors
Lost That C would use them to guide them
home and also navigate the rocks that
could cause their ships to crash this
allowed them to make it back to the
shore and this is similar to how Tabitha
has made it back home on top of this in
jungian archetypes it has a symbolic
meaning too with a lighthouse standing
for an individual's Consciousness in his
Memoirs young put it as a light that can
guide one out of darkness and its
potential use here could be to take
Tabitha out of the dream she's pushed
out of the Tower by the boy in white and
he sort of acted like a guardian angel
throughout this entire thing he saved
Victor from the massacre when he was a
kid and also held the characters out at
the end of season 1. now Victor's mother
someone who we know and after it as well
and I actually think that she's out in
the real world she went looking for the
White House and probably also had a
similar journey to what we see Tabitha
doing here Victor's mother said she was
going to save the children and visions
of them have plagued Tabitha throughout
the show so far so I think she's very
much going on the same Journey as her
and we might even discover that she's
out in the real world too sure she'll be
a lot older but I actually think Tabitha
might track her down there will probably
be new stories of a woman claiming she
escaped the town and then using their
knowledge they can send Tabitha back I
think it would be a real shame if Victor
wasn't reunited with her and his
Survivor so long that he deserves the
happy and now Victor discusses how they
found her body by the Bottle Tree and I
think that Tabitha's body might be
discovered there too in the from verse
it makes sense that when someone
transcends that their body would be
discovered cause in this world they've
just been pushed out a lighthouse in
order to get there they have to go
through the far away tree so I feel upon
being pushed at their Throne at the tree
as well we know his mother at least
traveled into it so for her to end up on
the outside could be due to a similar
thing so that thing in season 2 that her
family will come across a corpse and
then from here we'll see her out in the
outside world in the case of Mary we saw
how she was reunite with Christy and
it's possible that if you wanted enough
that you can be taken there there may
also exist far away trees in the real
world which could allow people to travel
in and out of the town this would mean
that the people running the show and
working with those in control also have
a way to get in and also get out very
loose dude times there but I think there
are some pointers at what could be going
on now there's also the possibility that
Victor's sister Eloise is the one she
could come across us outside like his
mother she was someone that was a key
part of his childhood but we never
actually found out what her fate was she
was simply there in the flashbacks and
then disappeared when we cut to present
day and though it is possible that she
passed during the massacre there may be
other things at work potentially her
Escape happened during this and she was
able to get out and flee which made
Victor stop looking for her I think in
general that he's pretty shook by his
mother's death and anything that feels
like it's gonna cause him to step out of
the quote-unquote limits of the town is
something that's gonna make him hold
back he's pretty much institutionalized
as he's lived there for as long as he
can remember and probably doesn't want
to go and lose his home guy's been
carrying that lunchbox around for years
as well and they might use that as a way
to find his sister now I've also seen
people discussing how when Tabitha looks
in the window we get a weird reflection
back I don't know if this is 100 the
case as it could be the lighting but I
have seen theories saying that we get a
blonde woman in the glass looking back
which could potentially be Eloise now if
we're gonna go with the simulation
Theory then there is another the
possibility that comes with this as well
many suspect that the town is either an
experiment or simulation and Tabitha
could have just woken up on the next
level I'm not sure of that but if the
reflection thing is in a reach then
potentially that's why it's been put
here it's also important to bear in mind
that the hospital is called Saint
Anthony's which we can see on the
background of a computer screen Anthony
is known as the patron saint of lost
things which Tabitha in the town also
represent potentially we also have more
effort here with Saints actually get
involved with the boy in white could
represent two he appeared to Victor as a
child and hasn't aged since then so
there is the possibility he could be in
a mortal guardian angel now for the next
part of the video I want to talk about
what else happens in the finale and then
I'm gonna go and give our review if
you're enjoying it so far though make
sure you subscribe to stick around like
Kelly did otherwise you gotta spend the
night in the box now we begin in the
aftermath of the Swarm that was
Unleashed at the end of episode 9 and
these have taken over Julie Randall and
Marielle Bound in an almost unresponsive
State they they then react by screaming
upon being touched this reminded me of
Kelly when she was stuck to the tree and
eventually she descended into violently
screaming once she hit a certain point
Boyd and Cole then decide to head out
into the woods which is where they began
to decipher that nursery rhyme it says
they come for three unless you stop the
melody and herein lies the key in how
they get saved but I'm not a rapper the
idea of there being three is also being
shown in the series before with there
being three people chained up in the
case of the guy on the wall later on
when Boyd's taken there we see married
Julian Randall chained up as well and
they're in a similar position to how
those people were destroying the music
box also destroys the holdover them
which is summing Sarah gets told through
the force speaking to her elsewhere we
then joined Donna at The Colony House
who's been under the microscope for most
of this season Randall gave a lot of
attention to her and even suspected at
one point that she was the person
working for the other team I don't think
that's the case though and instead I
actually think this is Tilly I also got
through time I've gone as quickly gone
with you Tom huge it adds to things
story for pointing out that she said she
had seven children and that there are
seven kids who appear at the bottom of
the well she also has seven people in
the prayer circle and earlier in the
season she seemed to know more than she
should she knew Boyd had just been
adding about and was also aware that
Fatima was pregnant sure she could have
guessed it by the fact she was glowing
because they say that a women who are
pregnant but she seems to slowly be
seeping into every aspect of the town
the idea of her being an old vulnerable
lady also means people don't put their
God up with her and she may be a wolf in
sheep's clothing spying on the town now
we have had the idea before that old and
frail looking people can be dangerous
and this is something that appeared from
episode 1. if you cast your mind back to
the first kill in that first episode The
Monster came knocking and the guys of an
old woman this could have definitely
been foreshadowing what's to come and my
money's on telly being the double agent
as in a few times now in some happy news
now in some happy new use Fatima and
Ellis decide to get married which
actually shows that there's some hope
and a home that can be made here this
happens in the room in which we first
met the characters back in episode 1 and
it's adorned with the artwork they've
created over the seasons I think it's
only once you start looking for a way
out that it potentially presents itself
but those who want to remain can live if
they survive as someone who's obsessing
over everything is Jade who's now start
to see the dead like how Boyd saw his
wife smashing bottles he attempts to
build a 3D model of the symbol and a
vision of Tom tells him to go down into
the tunnels this is where Tabitha went
into and had her own vision and the
well-entered sex metaphorically much in
the same way the lighthouse does
potentially a way out this symbol that
appears here may show that that's also
the case the children all sit around
looking about the sky and I was
wondering if this was a weird ritual
that keeps everyone here the idea of
bottles also comes across as well as
they're of course hanging up on the
Bottle Tree as well elsewhere we watch
Reggie start to go on a murder spree and
Boyd girls looking for a way to finally
destroy the Box this is when Reggie
Springs him accusing him of causing
Paula's death but in the end Boyd
manages to kill him eventually after
lighting the torch about the side of the
dungeon he then transported there and he
sees his dead wife who says illeges
prolonging their suffering he states
that destroying the Box will keep the
people in the town and they'll die in
even more agonizing death if he prolongs
it here I feel like right that that
there is the possibility that she might
have been writing her assumptions it was
all a dream and potentially her death
allowed her to go into the real world
you may also just be a manipulation
carried out by whatever's going on here
but Boyd it does stand up to her and
then destroys the Box she goes with it
too and this brings the three and also
stops the constant buzzing that we've
heard in the town now as Boyd goes into
the woods you might also notice
something different about the woods
themselves earlier in the season Victor
said the town had been in a constant
state of Summer but now that things were
starting to change and it was going into
the winter I think longer the town is a
mass populace there the more it starts
to Decay before in the end it eventually
dies off this is why the massacre was
carried out in Victor's childhood and it
gave the town enough blood to keep going
for the next few decades there's a
moment in the season when Tabitha's
climbing the lighthouse and we can see
heirs marked on some steps I think this
marks out the massacres and this
potentially happens in Cycles over and
over and over again a bottle was dropped
during the scene linking back to the
Bottle Tree which itself so far away
tree shown To Us by the boy in white
perhaps he's trying to get as many
people out before the next Massacre
begins or he sent Tabitha out as someone
who can bring help back another Massacre
definitely seems like it's around the
corner and we will likely get one
happening very soon now there are
seemingly good forces at work here too
and they seem to want that to happen we
have the boy in white and also the other
things in town like the Talisman and so
on and so forth these stop the evil
forces from completely running a Merc
and are likely the key to getting
everyone out of there we know there are
a few ways out in the case of Tabitha
and it may be possible to travel out by
walking when she makes it to the
lighthouse she gets a view over the area
and we see the cliffs that surround it
in a circular fashion I think passing
these will allow one to escape and no
they can't drive out because of the tree
they could potentially walk their way
out the boy in white clearly has some
insight to the things happening over and
over as he was the one who told Victor
to dig the correct amount of bodies
before the attack on colony house I kind
of feel like the three sacrifices might
be a way to appease the town which is
what Boyd's wife was also alluding to
carrying these out staves off the
massacre but in stopping them it causes
this to happen whatever is connected to
the worms is clearly very powerful as we
also had the monsters being killed by
them as well there's also the fact we
have the dog constantly popping up and I
have a theory that this might be linked
to the hikers potentially they go on
their walks and take their little Pooch
with them which wanders in and out of
the forest between the barriers this
then allows it to transverse between the
two and Tabitha might even use it as a
guide to get everyone out before the
next Massacre it seems to pop up
constantly and I'd love it if we haven't
revealed that this was a dog that
belonged to the hikers that then found
her anyway as you mentioned we end with
Tabitha being pushed out of the
lighthouse and now waking up somewhere
completely different
that ends the breakdown and my thoughts
for this episode but as for my thoughts
on the season it was a bloody Banger
filled with mystery horror and things
that kept me addicted to the show I want
to thank you guys from the bottom of my
heart are constantly messaging me over
the last nine weeks being like hey are
you gonna do from you should do from are
you doing from it was a hundred times a
day yeah but I appreciate it in the end
I'd never seen the series and eventually
I just caved in and decided one day that
I was gonna put it on from the first
scene I was completely hooked and then
the show took over my entire life me and
my wife binged watched the first season
in the space of about four days and
since then I've been absolutely hooked
feels like a mix between a Stephen King
Classic and a show like lost where the
horror level has been bumped up to 11. I
honestly thought that the format from
season one would just be something that
they stuck with with the monsters being
out in the woods trying to get them at
night however they went above and beyond
that in this season and decided to add
even more horror as the group went into
the woods now the monsters aren't the
scariest things in the show and it's
constantly getting better and better and
better now saying that the monsters
still pack a punch too and that episode
in which Elle gets stabbed and they have
to race to the hospital was the standout
scene for me don't in one take we get a
real scope of the area as they travel
from one side to the other in a
desperate Dash just seeing the monsters
slowly walk her there and reminds me how
terrifying something can be when it's
moving slowly and this vastly outweighs
using jump scares in my opinion I talked
about this in our Darth Vader video from
like last year but but one thing that
they do with that character is that they
never have him running he's always just
walking slowly and it's a technique
that's been used on characters like
Michael Myers and also the Terminator
just makes them terrifying and I thought
this stuff with the new characters was
really good too bringing in a literal
busload of people added a lot to the
show and we had Randall adding an extra
Dimension as well the conspiracy
theorist he started asking the questions
I'd been asking and seeing him slowly
letting his paranoia get the best of him
was a great addition all in all I feel
this is a brilliant show and I can't
overstate how much I enjoyed I'm so
happy you guys recommended it to me and
I'll definitely be around to talk about
the next one hopefully see you over then
too and obviously let me know your
thoughts in the comments section below
if you want to support the channel for
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below and
as a thank you you'll get early access
to videos every week we also have our
merch store over at shopzeroedition.com
which sells lots of nodie inspired
t-shirts hats and more we've just
launched a secret Invasion slash Pulp
Fiction inspired t-shirt so if you want
to head over then help us out then the
links in the description now if you want
something else to watch we've got a
secret Invasion video on screen right
now so definitely head over there right
after this by the way huge thank you for
sitting through the video I've been poor
and I'll see you next time you take care
peace
all right